[Música]
vamos a las noticias de la economía con
Jorge Hurtado buenas noches para usted
Jorge buenas noches Ángela nada
sorpresivo el tema con el que vamos a
abrir este segmento vamos a iniciar con
el tema de la muerte Cruzada en el
Ecuador de la disolución de la asamblea
nacional del presidente Guillermo lasso
Y es que ya el mandatario comenzó a
gobernar por decreto lanzó una nueva
reforma tributaria sí está de hecho es
la primera ley que lazo firma tras esta
controversial medida del decreto
contempla Un aumento de los gastos
deducibles anuales que podrá ser de
hasta 15.294 dólares dependiendo del
número de cargas familiares según datos
del gobierno en ese país existen 341.000
contribuyentes que pagan impuesto a la
renta y con esta reforma tributaria se
beneficiarían directamente el 99% que
tendrán cada uno Un ahorro promedio de
unos 558 dólares en su pago del impuesto
a la renta la nueva reforma tributaria
también Crea una tasa del 15% de
impuesto a la renta para las casas de
apuestas deportivas la primera reforma
tributaria transmitida por lazo en
diciembre del 2022 Recibió la negativa
de la asamblea nacional que votó por su
derogación lazo disolvió la asamblea en
medio de un juicio político de censura
que la oposición emprendió contra el
jefe de estado que lo acusan de
malversación de supuestas condiciones
perjudiciales para el estado en unos
contratos de transporte marítimo de
petróleo mire de las decisiones que tomé
lazo en estos días que le quedan de
mandato pues dependerá mucho la
estabilidad del país y la economía por
supuesto No es la excepción esta
decisión ella movió los mercados
bursátiles sin duda alguna y lo seguirá
siendo en los próximos días y meses el
bono ecuatoriano 2030 retrocedió un
4,15% durante el día y se ubicó en los
49,15 dólares Aunque al inicio de la
sesión incluso Ángela llegó a caer hasta
un 10% respecto al dato del lunes de por
sí el riesgo país ecuatoriano es el
tercero más alto de toda América Latina
tan solo por detrás de Venezuela y
Argentina a inicios de este año el
riesgo país de Ecuador rondaba los
puntos y estaba por debajo de El del
Salvador pero los bonos comenzaron a
caer en febrero cuando lazo perdió un
referéndum hasta ahora ningún presidente
de ese país había utilizado esta figura
de la muerte Cruzada pero lazo sabía que
de avanzar el juicio político en su
contra probablemente terminaría con su
destitución sin duda la inestabilidad
política ahí podría abonar a empeorar el
riesgo país y también ha devaluar sus
bonos veremos si esa inestabilidad
política se llega a dar o sea hay una
transición no hay que sea digamos
pacífica y tranquila hacia el nuevo
gobierno ahora donde quisiera Jorge que
también habláramos de la prórroga de la
iniciativa del mar Negro para el
transporte de granos desde Ucrania Este
era un tema también en el que había
muchísimas expectativas en los últimos
días y sobre todo cierta negativa de
parte de Rusia es importante mencionar
que desde que se introdujo este acuerdo
en julio del 2022 existe cierta
estabilidad en los precios mundiales de
los alimentos que tocaron un máximo
histórico tras la invasión en Rusia en
Ucrania Perdón pese a esto la ONU que de
mediador en el acuerdo afirma que la
crisis climática y otros choques
económicos hacen que los precios
mundiales de los elementos se mantengan
en máximo de diez años gracias a este
acuerdo Ucrania ha podido exportar unos
30,25 millones de toneladas de productos
agrícolas de los cuales el 50% fue maíz
y el 28% trigo la nueva extensión será
un alivio a los países de África medio
oriente y también Asia que dependen del
trigo la cebada aceites y otros
productos ucranianos
Moscú se resistía a esta renovación
exigiendo la salida de fertilizantes y
alimentos rusos a los mercados
internacionales de hecho según Rusia sus
exportaciones viven los efectos
colaterales de las sanciones de
occidente también Rusia pide la
reconexión del banco rosen costback al
sistema de comunicaciones financieras
Swift la renovación también de los
suministros de maquinaria agrícola y que
occidente elimina las restricciones en
materia de seguros y libre acceso a los
puertos Bueno Este sí es un tema en el
que hay incertidumbre y que podría
cambiar en cualquier momento vamos ya al
cierre Jorge el Día Mundial del internet
la ONU hizo un llamado para que se logre
una conectividad universal real estamos
lejos todavía de eso sin duda la brecha
digital Aún es grande entre países en
desarrollo y el resto del planeta en
2022 407 millones de personas de los
países menos desarrollados utilizaban
internet lo que representaba el 36% del
total de la población frente al 66% de
usuarios en el resto del mundo según
Naciones Unidas en los últimos 10 años
el tema de la conectividad se ha vuelto
más complejo y también exigente el
organismo firma que en los países en
desarrollo hay 720 millones de personas
que Siguen sin conexión y representan el
27% de la población mundial sin conexión
el Día Mundial de las telecomunicaciones
se celebra cada año el 17 de mayo desde
1969 para conmemorar la fundación de la
unión internacional de
telecomunicaciones y también otra fecha
importante que fue la firma del primer
convenio telegráfico internacional en
1865 y un derecho a la información que
está lejos de llegar a ser garantizado
pero gracias Jorge porque nos lo
recuerda y nos da más a inco para seguir
trabajando en el tema de nada y nos
vemos en la próxima no pero claro hoy
vamos a hacer una pequeña pausa pero ya
regresamos con el debate para seguir
hablando de lo que está pasando en
Ecuador
[Música]